cuántos de vosotros todavía hoy tiene
algún reto pendiente algún sueño por
cumplir en la vida
y cuántos de vosotros si todo fuese
posible os gustaría hacerlo
este mismo año
pero qué es lo que pasa
que cuando tu mente piensa en hacer eso
que nunca te ha atrevido de repente
viene aquí
pepitogrillo que te dice que no tienes
tiempo que no tienes dinero que tú no
eres lo suficientemente bueno y que
mejor el mes que viene o el año que
viene cuántos de vosotros cada vez que
ha venido ese sueño esa utopía a vuestra
cabeza le ha saltado pepitogrillo
muchas gracias soy antonio g y hoy vamos
a hacer un viaje todos juntos vamos a
intentar rescatar ese sueño que todos
tenéis por cumplir y vamos a eliminar
nuestras excusas lo voy a hacer con dos
historias aquí le gustan las historias
a todos vosotros muy bien
yo soy nómada digital
y esto de trabajar desde tu casa desde
cualquier lugar del mundo está bien está
muy bien pero no siempre no siempre fue
así
y voy a contar la historia de este niño
que nació en 1988
y cuando eres niño no tiene una
personalidad muy definida y empiezas a
hacer lo que otros te dicen que
supuestamente tienes que hacer tu padre
tu madre tu familia tus hermanos la
sociedad tus vecinos tu abuela tu primo
el colegio entonces a mí me dijeron que
cuando eras joven pues había que
cuidarse entonces empecé a correr para
tener una buena salud y ya
de adolescente pues quería ser más cool
entonces empecé a hacer fotografías en
blanco y negro y luego llegas a los 18
años y tienes que elegir algo tienes que
ir a la universidad porque así te
garantizan que garantizarán un buen
futuro entonces yo fui a la universidad
de arquitectura y empecé a hacer
dibujitos diseño a mano en digital pero
cuando salí el panorama laboral era
bastante interesante y en lugar de
aceptar trabajos mal remunerados por 300
euros al mes o trabajar gratis decidí
irme a la calle con mi trompeta montar
un grupo de funk y tocábamos en
escenario no sé mucho esa foto pero ahí
estamos en festivales realmente esto no
me permitía cumplir mi sueño porque
tenía que estar en un sitio fijo y
además hemos 14 personas en la banda con
lo cual es repartir beneficios como
comprenderá y no nos daba mucho
el 9 de marzo de 2016 despedida es dejar
pensar en los otros y comenzar a pensar
en mí y cumplir este sueño que hacía
muchísimos años que yo tenía y era dar
la vuelta al mundo al principio lo iba a
hacer solo pero me enamoré de cris y
juntos nos fuimos a dar esta vuelta al
mundo
empezamos en noruega para cumplir un
sueño dentro de un sueño que era visitar
las auroras boreales y después de mil
trece días tres años aparecimos en cuba
en américa fuimos todo el camino hacia
el este hasta llegar allá y volver aquí
españa en total fueron como digo mil
trece días voy a ir anotando alguna
cosita vale
en esos mil trece días nos dio tiempo a
hacer muchas cosas
por ejemplo recorrer la montaña más alta
del planeta en los himalaya en nepal
cuando estuvimos en el punto más alto
decidimos bajar al más bajo que era el
mar muerto en jordania y luego decidimos
bajar un poquito más a las grutas
visitamos los cenotes de mexico y
decidimos seguir bajando porque en una
gruta así podríamos bucear pues
estuvimos haciendo buceo en el mar rojo
en egipto y una vez que volvimos a la
superficie nos encontramos con el
paraíso con la polinesia pero esto de
tanta agua como que nos cansó entonces
decidimos comenzar a volar y estuvimos
visitando a eeuu el gran cañón en
concreto en helicóptero cuando decidimos
bajar del cielo lo hicimos tirando de un
avión en nueva zelanda y cuando llegamos
a abajo dijimos por qué no visitamos esa
conexión entre tierra y el cielo y
visitamos los templos del mundo así
estuvimos en el taj mahal en agra en
india visitando los templos de japón
visitando los nuevos templos modernos
como las torres
en kuala lumpur malasia visitando
también los templos las maravillas
naturales y durante todo ese tiempo pues
yo tenía que trabajar porque mi empresa
seguía funcionando 24/7 y empecé a
buscarme oficinas que me motivaron a
trabajar entonces alquile una oficina
aquí en la terraza enfrente de las
pirámides de guiza en egipto también
tuve otros rinconcitos muy interesantes
en turquía
la paz y la armonía de la oficina de
japón en nueva zelanda decidimos comprar
una furgoneta y estuvimos tres meses
viviendo en esta furgoneta eso era la
cama pero la cama se plegaba y había dos
asientos hicimos una instalación
eléctrica montamos como un coworking
dentro para que la misma furgoneta nos
sirviera de casa y del lugar de trabajo
y también pude disfrutar de trabajar en
la piscina respondiendo email o hablando
con mi equipo con las vistas del golfo
de tailandia también de vez en cuando me
echaba fotos de postureo esto es la
polinesia o en el top 3 mejor hoteles de
asia y en total ya he tenido la suerte
de recorrer
61 países
quedan muchos pero la verdad que 61 está
bastante bien durante todo ese tiempo
también me empezaron a invitar a
conferencias como la de hoy entonces de
repente estaba en buenos aires y me
invitaban una conferencia o iba ciudad
de méxico me enviaba en nada otra
recorría algunos países de latinoamérica
a contando un poco mi historia y a la
vuelta de españa pues también me
empezaron a llamar más personas para
compartir lo que hoy os estoy contando
hasta el día de hoy que no tenía la foto
de la charla ted porque todavía no había
pasado estamos aquí así que el año que
viene igual si me invitan una derecha de
látex de otro sitio
aquí la otra otra imagen durante todo
ese tiempo como decía mi empresa seguía
funcionando creé un equipo y en esos
cuatro años cuando llegué hablé con la
project manager con esther con la
directora de operaciones me hizo este
antonio que ya hemos superado el millón
de euros de facturación mientras tú
estaba viajando entonces vamos apuntar
también esa cifra
un millón
mi empresa como han dicho tengo una
escuela ayudamos a otras personas que
también quieren trabajar desde su casa a
través de empleos emergentes que lo
pueden hacer online y ya hemos ayudado a
4 mil 274 personas lo mejor de todo que
como es online lo hemos hecho desde 58
países 4.274
personas
algunos dicen pero como te da tiempo a
hacer todo esto pues la verdad es que la
media de 2018 fue que trabaje 91 horas
al mes no sé si es mucho o es poco pero
normalmente la persona trabajan
40 horas
a la semana yo trabajaba 91 al mes de
media lo mido todo con una aplicación
para saber lo que hago y lo que dejó de
hacer
y ahora me pregunto
a quien le gustaría vivir así viajando
con mil trece días visitando más de 60
países facturando un millón de euros
ayudando a 4 mil 274 personas y
trabajando solo 91 horas al mes
hay algunos que no levantan la mano
luego me contáis por la noche vuestros
sueños
si esta historia os ha parecido
interesante la mía no es nada comparado
con la que os voy a contar ahora y en
las de estas chicas las sirves debería
de tener una imagen que me gustaría que
cogiera y es ahora vale esa fotografía
es justo esta y lo que vais a hacer es
mirarla y sacar una palabra un concepto
que os exprese esa imagen sé que todos
tenéis un bolígrafo y una libreta
entonces saca de ese bolígrafo y
escribir esa palabra detrás de la imagen
vale un concepto buscar esa palabra
ahora me voy a dar una vuelta por aquí
debajo y os voy a ir tocando algunos de
vosotros y me vais a decir esa palabra
en voz alta
la tenemos escribirla es importante para
el resto de vuestras vidas
[Música]
piensa
especial
una alegría
[Música]
sorprendente
gracias
[Música]
una alegría ante esa palabra porque
ahora nos vamos a ir todos juntos del
día dos
cerramos los ojos y nos vamos a ir todos
juntos a la india hacemos
[Música]
y ya estamos en el año
bain y es un país fantástico lo primero
que pasa cuando llegas a la india es que
lo hueles y de repente cuando llegas
lo abres y es el cajón de la especia de
entra por tu nariz es olor a pimienta la
cúrcuma cardamomo aburrió la india huele
aburrido respira
[Música]
encarnado en una niña de 14 años
una niña que está cuando en el colegio
porque la india también es diversión y
escuchas a todas las niñas ya todos los
niños de ese colegio que son tus amigos
cantando y riendo
y la india son colores también todo el
verde el amarillo el rojo el gordura
todo está lleno de flores disfrutas
y la india
y llega el momento en salir del colegio
así que vas caminando
[Música]
[Risas]
es tu hijo
tienes 14 años caminando a la puerta de
las notas que algo está mal
abre la puerta de tu casa ahí está tu
padre esperándote con una botella de
ácido en la mano
una botella de ácido que te rocía
[Música]
sigue rociando con ácido
hasta que tu hijo
[Música]
y
y la salida ante el juez en te duele
sí
[Música]
y ahora
y
y sigue con los ojos cerrados y
respirando
mentalmente mira tus brazos y ver todas
esas heridas todas esas cicatrices
pero ya no hay dolor no hay dolor físico
y mental y emocional sólo hay perdón y
de repente de esa herida brota una luz
blanca quién
todo es tu cuerpo envuélvete siéntelo
siente con tus ojos cerrados esa luz
blanca que te llega llena de paz de amor
de alegría y de repente en esa luz
blanca aparece esa palabra esa palabra
que han dicho tus compañeros esa palabra
que tú has escrito o que has pensado y
ahora quiero que digas en voz alta esa
palabra
dime cuál es esa palabra
[Música]
y siente esa palabra retira la palabra
porque es tu anclaje para cumplir tu
sueño repite esa palabra en voz alta
más alto no escucho cuál es esa palabra
[Música]
podéis abrir los ojos
esta historia no acabó de compartir pues
la que nosotros mismos vivimos cuando
visitamos el taj mahal en agra en la
india llegamos a después de visitar
altas mahal fuimos a las sirves que son
estas chicas tenemos otra vez visto las
fotografías
[Música]
y allí entramos de repente me encuentro
a 10-12 mujeres completamente reformadas
algunas le faltaban las manos otras las
piernas otras no tenían los ojos no
podían ver pero estaban alegres están
felices estaban hablando cantando entre
ellas riendo haciéndose bromas
así que nos tomamos algo allí cristian
de hoy en los compañeros
al terminar de un beso y por favor le
podría hacer una entrevista a una de
ellas porque tenemos un proyecto
sociológico de ir haciendo entrevistas a
diferentes personas del mundo para que
compartirán su historia y nosotros la
pudiéramos divulgar
allá se dieron y en esa entrevista fue
justo cuando me compartieron lo que yo
hemos hecho una pequeña parte la
historia mucho más dura
real me di cuenta de que nadie de
nosotros tenemos
si ella no las tienen y tampoco pueden
tenerla
en ese momento cuando terminamos la
entrevista ella de repente cerraron el
local no esperamos sólo fueron a un
aparato de música enorme con un montón
de altavoces pusieron la música a toda
y comenzaron a saltar a reír a
gritar
y a que nosotros les acompañaron la
compañera con esos bailes sin duda este
tenía
la verdad que fue muy divertido pero yo
seguía sin entenderlo en ese momento en
el que me hice la foto está acompañada
de dos ellas flipaban con rastas
yo privado con ella y al interesado a mi
pelo que a mí me interesaba su historia
y de repente fue en ese momento cuando
estaba con ella y le pregunté a una de
ellas
como podéis ser tan valiente que la gran
mayoría de personas general
y ella me miró
antonio
no haya cosas otra vida
[Música]